- Alright Zach, so my problem,
I feel like you could relate to a little.
- Facial hair?
- Yeah, totally.
- I sit next to someone and she
eats the same salad everyday
and the salad dressing is so smelly.
I understand it's healthy for
you but I can't deal with it.
- I sit across from someone
and we share a foot
rest underneath our desk
and they take up the whole
foot rest but not only that
but their feet goes way past it
and so sometimes it hits my legs.
- My boss's birthday is
coming up and I'm curious what
is an appropriate gift?
- I've been at BuzzFeed
for a year and a half now
and there's a co-worker of
mine who's been spelling
my name wrong the entire time.
- Do you know what kind
of salad dressing it is?
Is it ranch?
- It's a raspberry vinaigrette.
- Oh God,
one of the worst.
- From a health food store.
On kale.
- Yeah, raspberry vinaigrette. Kale.
Three words I've never liked.
It's strange that you share
a foot rest with someone.
I mean, what's the foot
rest budget at BuzzFeed?
Do you know?
- I'm not sure about that.
- Does he have tattoos?
- No tattoos that I've seen.
I've never seen him naked.
I don't know what he looks like.
- Do you think maybe if you ask him
to see him naked for his birthday?
- That would be a gift for him?
- Yeah.
Hey, can I see you
naked for your birthday?
How do you spell it?
- L-I-N-D-S-A-Y.
They spell it E-Y.
- This is tough because,
well, the thing is,
is that Lindsay, or excuse me Lind-zhay.
I don't like her eating at her desk.
I don't think that that's,
I think that's rude.
I think that's where,
that's the advice I'm gonna give you
is tell her to eat in her car.
- My sister's feet smell like Doritos
and I think if you could maybe get
a good Dorito sweat going,
take your shoes off,
maybe wear some wool socks
and then get a good foot sweat,
prop your feet up.
That lady ain't gonna get
her feet close to yours, yep.
- Just be honest with him.
Say I got you this gift
certificate to Souplantation.
I'm assuming that's an expensive gift.
- It's a hot spot.
- I did it 'cause I
need you to promote me.
I'll tell ya a true story
apropos of this a little bit.
My brother's name is
Greg and five years ago,
I just call my sister Mia and I'm like,
Mia, let's start calling
Greg, Craig, for no reason.
For five years, we've called him Craig.
Text him, "Hey Craig, are you going home
for Thanksgiving?"
He's never said anything about it.
He's winning.
So if you don't let things get to you
and if you actually change your name
to the correct spelling, let's be honest -
- Wait a minute.
- Let's be honest.
- You think it should,
Lindsay Lohan spells hers A-Y
and if Lindsay does it, it's right.
- How many followers does she have now?
- Probably a couple mil.
(laughter)
- Do you mind if I?
- Please, I got it in junior
high like 13 years ago.
- We'll be right back with
the world's worst bragger.
(laughter)